che cosa sono queste cose a tutti è
tornati suite sommersi dai regali dei
vostri regali però tutti i regali che se
avete portato al firma copie obiettivo
sono tutti grazie grazie grazie a tutti
allora oggi andremo aprire tutti i
regali conferma copie grazie ancora
tantissimo non solo a chi portosi regali
battute le persone che sono venute
genitori che avevano accompagnato fatto
allora per noi è stata un'emozione
grandissima vedervi è stato incredibile
ci siamo emozionati un sacco eravamo
felicissimi
e stato bellissimo abbracciarvi parlare
un po liuc.it come vi chiamo volte
chissà quanti anni avete scherzare a
ridere con voi tutto troppo bello era
surreale quasi perché voi siete abituati
a vederci
ma noi vediamo solo i vostri commenti ma
non vi abbia mai visto che ci abbraccia
volta eravate troppo belli grazie anche
per tutte le foto che ci avete mandato
in questi ultimi giorni dopo dopo firma
copie appunto è stato bello ricordarvi
voi di giorno in giorno si ama
ringraziare non solo le persone che sono
venute in firma copie ma anche i
genitori che vi pare anche cielo la zia
che ha accompagnato la piccola e
facciano i genitori che i parenti che vi
hanno accompagnato anche perché sono
stati comunque pazienti hanno aspettato
soprattutto roma e napoli e che avete
aspettato tanto in fila quindi vi
ringraziamo tantissimo tra l'altro i
genitori erano simpatici steelers hanno
fermato nelle toy stessa per incappata
tanti genitori che ci seguono anche
siamo
ciao sono detta guardiamo sempre tutti
assieme all'ora di pranzo il pomeriggio
ancora incerto fate parte della famiglia
ormai troppo carini veramente poi c'è
stata una mamma napoli che mi ha detto
complimenti sei molto più bella dal vivo
che invidio molto felice che mia figlia
mi guardi ha detto perché io controllo
cosa guarda su youtube e voi siete
genuini veronese luini
insomma siamo stati felicissimi sirigu
tra voi che di incontrare i vostri
genitori che erano super carini super
gentili e siete stati super affettuosi e
grazie mille brutte le cose che se avete
portato non c'era bisogno davvero 3
anche per il cibo e sei trovato a prato
ovviamente quello non ci sarà perché io
nel frattempo l'ho mangiato qualche cosa
c'è però ancora decisivo è la risposta
allora perché io di solito e dopo subito
a mangiarmi che i cioccolatini chiamo
avete regalato dei genitori che non
[Musica]
abbiamo inquadratura così vediamo meglio
tutte e due tele già citato già pasta
salita cane allora iniziamo dalla prima
bustina allora ovviamente non sono in
ordine di incontro di persone perché non
potevamo appunto sistemarli tutti in
ordine quindi andiamo così a caso allora
questo bustina e penalizzata
abbiamo una partita storica stati chiusi
da graham incredibile primark live act
halloween intelligente straordinaria
reale e un sacco di altre cose qua
dentro abbiamo wow della colla
trasparente in penna fantastico un
contenitore molto per poi mettere lo
slime fantastico grazie ha fatto proprio
kit qualsiasi
delle stelline da mettere offline quindi
immagino che vuole che faccia proprio lo
slime cosa se queste cose possiamo poi
possiamo fare noi ricordiamo le cose ti
argentati bellissimi sono senza che sia
lo stesso collato no mi sembra colorata
sembra viola un ricordo che carino e con
dentro c'è penso che sia un super mini
slime che ho paura che sia un po sciolto
durante il viaggio
e poi se la palettina per mischiare il
tutto grazie mille all'ora prossimo
messina e da iva e mentre lui ha
inoltrato mirko bambini adulti e sacconi
mi chiamate non mi riconoscerai mappe
tra comunque mi avevano risposto io lo
sa mi scusai va subito detto anche il
cognome di natale che carino grazie da
interpetrano bravi dovete firmare tutto
che carini sono dei pennarelli colorati
no sono degli iniziatori colorati hanno
le faccine degli attacchi sono lì per
vitale come grazie ed un cioccolato
della caffarella tra l'altro sono anche
super politica nella confezione vostri
regali grazie mille grazie allora qua
abbiamo la firma si chiama oro giallo
commercianti ma vediamo che c'è da parti
di camilla non godo camilla crab per
labbra che carina io ho fatto anche il
gestore dello scalo al caffè ma il
carissimo per una fata confezione che
calerà il sacchetto amici che cosa siamo
questo concetto delle scimmiette mi sono
voltata morte
allora
mentana vi spiego il perché guardate
sono delle scimmie sono delle scimmie
tema pensavo fossero fermi perché la
coda e marrone lunga ma mi sembra strano
dei vermi dentro ma poi tutto magari
sono cresciuti dopo non lo so san
massimo d'oro tra l'altro massa di
cioccolato grazie camilla carinissimo
aragostine che corrono
ho paura quando sappiamo delle figurine
del nelal corsa che carine tale perché è
una bambina a forma di compromesso
chiave inglese che carina questo penso
che sia un balsamo labbra a sia proprio
un lipgloss colorato in ville cavina
carinissime queste cose grazie mille per
essere venuto per avermi portato queste
cose alte rara vediamo un po per la sepa
dentro non ho due slime e sono in
taffettà bene bene
sono super impacchettati bene così
almeno non si sono distrutti
allora gli slam e li apriamo tutti dopo
allora prossimo non c'è scritto il nome
purtroppo vogliamo forse c'è dentro
giorni ora hanno aspetta
in pratica se come non ci stava tutto in
valigia cioè non potro valigie ma non ci
stava tutto alcune cose sono un po
mischiate perché non c'era spazio quindi
devo leggere i nomi sopra e in questa
purtroppo non c'è nessun nome quindi
scrivimi nei commenti
la bimba che mi ha portato appunto la
qustione di pandora con questa slide
carinissimo rosa dentro scrittore di con
i motivi del commento
io e invece qua abbiamo uno slime da
antonia grazie mille questi slanci
offriamo poi tutti e se è vero abbiamo
una bustina da rosa che mi ricordo era a
napoli si era super carina allora
abbiamo room o il sacchi 8 carinissimo
eccolo qua nastrino questo tipo coli per
ora guardate qua c'è scritto per il tuo
grosso che scaricano investigate
impazziscono a giocare con queste cose
poi un argentina ei braccialetti
nettamente una rosa perché si chiamava
rosa che carina grazie mille rosa per
queste cose ma abbiamo una busto
raggirando non ci sta in camera con
questo spirito da samuele e pietro che
carini 1 slime da aurora per tanta
carinissimo viola poi lo apriamo qui
ho disegnato bimbo hanno dato che è
morto poco tempo fa non so se avete
visto appunto corini grazie ora e poi
c'è una ricetta che la clay di tiger
grazie mille ho preso dodicesimo con
disegno di pippo che mi manca tantissimo
grazie mille all ora è apparso le cose
stavano qua dentro sempre da samuel
eto'o e pietro non potevo farlo meglio
non potevo farlo meglio scusa ma chiesto
che cosa la buccia
queste sono pochi eh si cari toro manca
lo spazio per l'italia mettiamo pure qui
è carinissimo grazie allora poi abbiamo
uno slalom da legni meglio che mi piace
molto il viola perché molto ricorrente
questo colore allora questa è la prima o
dopo discusso lo slam brutto ma
purtroppo in casa loro sono una colla
della pin up e il comunque ti adoro che
carino grazie ogni soprattutto di quelle
splendor stiamo parlando allora è pietro
e pietro che ha scritto questo
bigliettino perché è la stessa scrittura
da pietro scusa se non è bello io non ti
preoccupare
allora voi lo apro assieme al gas allora
questo per anita da vittoria e viola
contro uno slide successo qualcosa di
strano ma dovendo comunque andiamo a
vederlo meglio dopo allora serenità e
vitale vediamo un po questa letterina
il disegno del nostro logo dall asl sue
dita e soli vitale c'è il pezzo di pizza
e gras coca cola per capitale è un
maggiore carinissimo questo disegno
grazia se sei regali sono pochi o banali
ma andavo di fretta e mia mamma ne sa
qualcosa ti amo vai sempre avanti segui
il tuo cammino non cambiare mai ti amano
possa esprimere tutto il mio amore per
te non è semplice lettera saluti a me la
mia amica anna io sono rosa anno non è
potuto venire le dispiaceva molto perché
anche lei come me un altro grandissimo a
fans ciao vado comunque per l'essere
questi due righe qui sopra ti serviranno
gli occhiali di harry potter e perché
questo più piccolo
quindi vi saluto rosa e anna grazie
mille per questo di personaggio lo hanno
regalato le gemelline mi sembra di
capire che sono film non mi dire è un
gioco fighissimo
in pratica è un gioco in cui tir il dato
è a seconda di quale casella capiti devi
aggiungere libri 10 sono tutte le regole
sì so se sono qui le scritte le regole
allora corvia un altro foglio
conflittualità stories usa gaia fumo ecc
lo verde si rotta e verso volta team
giallo grazie
abbiamo dato disegno bellissimo c'è
scritto annita ti amo da mele con slide
grazie mille per questo disegno
bellissimo simoni
allora sì scritto ciao nì tastiera
merito per preferita ti prendo come
esempio per il tuo ottimismo 6
fantastiche quando guarda i tuoi video
mi sembra di stare con te che carina e
carola chiarello detto una cosa per
vitale
tutto tutto si sono delle caramella alla
mora e al limone sociale grazie caro
e poi c'è un altro disegno vediamo
[Applauso]
domani sera mi ha fatto uguale eppure
quasi evitare che gli somiglia con la
circolare con la trasporto perché europa
grazie mi sciolgo veramente carini ma
varia
grazie grazie mille
abbiamo da chiara 1 slime fatto da lei
faty sono sulle decorazioni dentro poi
andiamo dell'asse ma anche il costo il
viola incredibile il colore che mi piace
di più fedeli tra il bel viola o forse
l'ho detto anch'io in qualche video che
mi piaceva il mio level avete fatto
tutti i viola e che purtroppo non è
firmato ma è bellissimo guardate gestito
alita stories è bellissimo per i propri
sapere di commenti come ti chiami grazie
mille per questo bracciale carinissimo è
anche questo e viole fruibile scusa
tutti i viola rosa carinissimo grazie
vediamo se c'e la firma da qualche parte
torcolato lo slime un po da maya e bea e
beh sì me lo ricordo che gli ho detto
anche le altre di un'aia allora
erano gemelle allora abbiamo due presso
degli stalli se poi queste palline hanno
uno stupendo sono color pastello mai
avuto delle palline così per lo slam
quindi ringrazio tantissimo grazie mille
unità da matilde è quasi una letterina
gli diamo fosse un pupazzetto di un
giochino che carino da slime fatto dalle
immagino un altro slime da matilda e
asia e mati questo blu quindi abbiamo un
altro colore a destra da matilde fu
affatto corazzino colorato si voglio
veramente tanto tanto tanto bene grazie
allora qua bambina mi ha regalato tutti
questi pupazzetti quindi scrivimi nei
commenti come ti chiami perché purtroppo
non sono firmati per le prossime volte
che ci conteremo mi raccomando firmate
ogni minima cosa perché appunto si
potrebbero disperdere quindi grazie
mille per tutti questi pupazzetti sono
tantissimi inclusione credibile ma
ricordatevi se adesso in un video che il
mio slam preferito e viola perché sono
sati viola allora da daniele per aiutati
ad ora l'itas è la mia vita senza di te
non avrei mai scoperto la creatività
seguimi su instagram a next music
vattene
bob king che ho incontrato a milano da
dolcissimo irlandese con i capelli rossi
gli occhi azzuri supercar grazie daniele
dop offriamo lo slime grazie mille ri
dolcissimo
in pratica da libia braccia otto e mezzo
che buon odore
siamo da milena per anita flavis live ti
voglio bene che carina anche questo lo
abbiamo tolto da bambino piccolo piccolo
che il dolce e carina un altro klein da
londra bellissimo nome quindi questo
mese abbiamo lo apriamo dopo butterfly
ma ci facciamo un sacco di domande
milano ti ricordi sono stati sparati da
alessia color di star che bella di me lo
ricordo che mio marito certi là dentro
l'aria vita siriano line boldini anche
questo lo apriamo grazie mille alessia
per questi regalini mi ha portati perché
non sono firmati quindi mi raccomando
firmato sempre tutto comunque grazie
mille per questi slime poi giardini
e lei nascosti non ho fatto tempo
mangiarli no l'hanno regalato a me come
una penna con un ricordo che bello
grazie carinissima scrivetemi nei
commenti kiss me l'ha regalata perché
non c'è la firma ci sono questi 2
squizzi di halloween
grazie mille chi me le ha regalate
ricordatevi di firmare sempre tutto
anche attaccando un pezzo di carta con
il nome ora qua abbiamo per anni della
nudo è nudo è rita vediamo un po che sia
uno slang questo addio se la crema gli
occhi ma forse l'hanno riempita con
qualcos'altro forse per crema per gli
occhi per mettere per metterla nello
sliven l'acido borico però è un po si è
aperto scherzo così e quindi forse ne è
caduto un po matros line
forse ma ci sono dei titoli di rosa
quindi grazie mille nudo è rita allora
questo eta che vendono un nome stupendo
vuol dire paradiso in inglese
quindi non mi ha regalato un bene flime
dopo andiamo ad aprirlo assieme questo e
rosa equa purtroppo non c'è la firma
vediamo cosa c'è qua dentro
senza fine avrà messaggi dove abbiamo
uno e blind a ginevra che ha fatto dalla
apple
creiamo la metà ce l'ho io vedo che non
vede nello stress line per aiutare da
ginevra qui abbiamo un perfetto e molti
un nastrino natalizio e qua c'è una
cosina del tesoro con contanti quando le
perline dentro e questo è un giochino di
lupi che sono al pianoforte
grazie mille se non lo so non se il 9
purtroppo col diavolo d'un padova e
mezzo il 9 forse l'ha fatto apposta per
farmi uno scherzetto dobbiamo vederlo
meglio c'è uno slam che coinvolto
purtroppo ha perso un sacco di liquido
questi live c'è un altro slime arancione
però purtroppo lo c'è scritto il nome
abbiamo uno slide e se per aretha
stories da alice e viola butters live
fatto in casa
grazie mille alice il viola poi lo
offriamo c'è un'altra slime da valentino
per anita stories
grazie mille cosa che persino dei
trucchi penso siano degli ombretti per
anita da nudo e rita grazie mille per
questi trucchi sera una bambina piccola
costerà barese che mi ha regalato questi
bracciali ma non c'è scritto il nome
purtroppo grazie comunque dice uno slime
scusate da licia
a me le ricordo litio che avevo detto
anche che io da piccola guardavo sempre
kiss milizia
ridere comunque si chiama lizza slime da
lì poi fa abbiamo un altro perle slime
fatto da licia grazie mille
e poi squadra ci sono delle creazioni
primo è qui si augurino questo è uno
squisito forma di donut cari vivo e poi
messina che corrono fosse un biscottino
poi le mosse bravissimo lizza davvero
non so se riuscirei a farle
e poi se un giorno c'è un gelatino se
anche il cosino per appenderlo che
carino bellissimo bravissima poi c'è una
pizza tutte le cose preferite di vitale
una pizza margherita che così se un
fondino con il corno da un accordo su
queste cose
grazie lizza allora vediamola le
stelline
spero che gli slam si piazzano e anche
disegnato cui si becca riviste un
baratto in l'acqua dello stato di
ributtarsi il lodo grazie a false in un
flame da giorgia per anita questo è
azzurro grazie mille fatto in casa copia
del twist i frozen wow
grazie mille le barre d'opera lite e
vitale uno per te e uno per vita averci
al cielo che cos'è e carina che f
bellissimi grazie tra l'altro noi
adoriamo puskin e quindi sono due
portachiavi cuscino
vi piace la dentro la pole e voip andrea
ammette se questo dentro la busta anno
quell'altro l'asciugamano tappeto
volante grazie prendo lo uso pubblico a
questo qua fantastico a roma non l'ha
detta regalato ed è l'amuleto contro il
verde c'è marchetti mielata è dire no
perché non te la firma spruzzi stima
firma lo so che fare comunque mi hanno
detto che questo è l'amuleto contro il
verde invece una sfida essere di aprirlo
per che superi il pacchetto per aprirlo
alla prima prima squadra stiamo alle
squadre si svilisca vi vogliamo
ringraziare questo sito listicket.it
rapito i regali sono 20 qualche
fragranza e mia cioè di alessandro
profumo
ti amiamo grazie da federica alessandra
salvi l'iniziale fase altre stelline
l'idea della muletta comprerebbe e
implenia
pur idv serpente allora c'è una collana
perde aero mi ricordo anche perché loro
mi hanno detto bene collana anti
sfortuna del bene o no vabbè vite troppo
simpatico e veramente
grazie mille funzionerà funzionerà
vedremo allora quasi un regalino da
ester meno male lei firmato l'inter
grazie tra l'altro mi servivano proprio
ci sono dei glitter argentati dei
glitter rossi grazie mille ad appiano
una letterina dava leggiamo stesse
regole del monopoly si è scritto ma ci
fosse un gioco per anita da lance è un
gioco volo polico permettere per fare
gli ingredienti dello slang quindi sono
orbis colorante rosa onore per lo
spaccio gestito colore verde cosa
grazie mille per questo gioco aggiungi
qualcosa che oggi sul serio a questi
sono le carte da pescare serva poi tra
l'altro impegnato staff costruire questi
giochi creativi le da zero grazie
castellino piccolino dacca villani the
stories sei la mia isola sempre i tre
trucchi per la scuola grazie miele
camilla un bacione un'altra letterina
anita e vitale una semi s'avventa se
dolcissima grazie series offerto visto
che sono riemerse locali the story faced
asca d'oro i tuoi video per realizzato
resi da carla con la k grazie carlo
a me lo ricordo perché la prima persona
che ho incontrato in assoluto perché
l'ho incontrata per strada mentre stava
andando alla libreria a varese e si
chiama ali da controtelai la mamma
pochissime e questo disegni stupendo
disegnato milu perché sapete che mi
spiace tantissimo b2 ed è bellissimo
oltre insegnato benissimo e anche
colorato super bene con le sfumature
quindi grazie mille a vita bellissimo è
uno slime però purtroppo non è firmato
quindi non so di chi sia ascrivibile i
commenti in leicester e spero che il mio
sogno il mio disegno ti piacerà ti adoro
sono così contenta di vedermi e
incontrarti pecorino grassina youtube
preferita abbiamo tantissime cose uguali
ad ora non c'e la firma e la rosa mi
piace a tantissimi suoi video sono
disegnati vari gatti grazie ma non c'è
la firma accesso la stessa 0 film
l'angelo maledizione del verde certo le
steli tale tutto colorato con il
pastello per alice vitale da caterina
grazie mille caterina tiraggio gli odori
da gaia e sarà al love paris st
siamo le vostre più gravi in palmi ma lo
sly in verde è stata siamo felicissimi
di essere venuto al vostro inconscio in
via troviamo grazie allora questa
disegna il suo sforzo da kimberlin velo
di coro perché voi piace trovo questo
disegno è fantastico all'oro rosso è
stato deve lo faccio vedere meglio prima
vi saluto perché ha chiesto anche di
salutare le stime che l'istituto saluto
kimberly è il disegno stupendo poi
saluto giulia già da una pregiata 2 e
velino federica linda è elena ciao
guardate questo disegno quanto è bello
se ci siamo io non scusate io è vitale
io la faccia arrabbiata e scrive la
maledizione base ha colpito ancora tim
roth ha cioè guardate quanti hanno fatto
bene ha ammesso anche la paletta rosa ce
lo slime ci sono i colori ma dentro
anche la ruota il fatto la ruota è
perfetta c'è anche scritto scambio occhi
chiusi c'è è bellissimo il tavolo bianco
e poi vitale c'è scritto tipo mostarda
si facciano a mistery box live un'altra
mistery box cioè bravissimo a kimberly
così disse grazie a quei grazie mille
cose c'è un lato nello specifico per
evitare perché grazie
che carino due giorni tua vita
alessandro poi c'è scritto con affetto
sofia e cristel s1 squisita che carino
grassi questa è una lettera
una sensazione unicorno è stupendo
grazie mille
ora di testori senza anche atterrita
giovani un bellissimo anche pazza ciao
da a liszt aggressiva grazie a mina a
volte tutte queste letterine carinissima
e grazie nino sia affatto questo vi
ritratto carinissimo grazie mille luci e
tanto carino da band ha fatto un altro
nostro ritratto un'altra challenge che
coach ecco dico quello sly behrami a
nessuno e se anche la ruota ancora
questo e per lo scambio ci somigliamo
sta cosa tra l'altro i rosa vitale
giallo col soggetto tratti lisabetta o
questo è di chiara e guardate in forze
la copertina del libro tra tre le chiede
scusa stampate non stava funzionando
molto bene ma non paese bellissimo la
copertina del mio libro stampata
poi c'è una mia foto questa è di un
video s m r o soppressioni colore degli
occhi sembrato viola poi se quest altra
mia foto che carina e poi se una lettera
e la lettera va bene la tv privata
perché per me però si saluto chiara
grassi non le hai del cibo
sì sono proprio io
l'altra lettera da anna oggi ti vedo ti
darò quell'abbraccio che ho sempre
sognato e forse ci faremo una foto
perché sei bellissima simpatica carina e
dolce sarà uno dei giorni più belli
della mia vita lo ricorderò bruno solo
mio finito 6 dolcissima
grazie grazie se lo fate di giada e
giorgia grazie mille la prima volta che
incontriamo dal vino youtube per tutto
il resto il family grazie all'esordio
abbiamo un la fis live da alice da alice
grazie mille per questo classes line ma
se una letterina da claudia a roma che
ci tengo a salutare e contato mio
fratello insomma grazie mille flavia per
la pazienza per aver aspettato e ti
mando un abbraccio e un bacio fortissimo
ci sono delle decorazioni stato al 30 fu
profumo del firmato e anche di mister fa
sapere l'ora faceva lui scrisse secondo
te è un perfetto un prospetto come
sembra o lo fa grazie carinissimo
peccato che non c'e il nuovo qua no
vabbè guardate questo disegno io sono
scioccata da quanto bello in ciò che
questo cartello c'è io sono bellissimo e
questo disegno sono molto più bella che
nella realtà grazie e che c'è
soprattutto lo slime argentato un mouse
appunto tempo avete messo a farlo questo
l'ha fatto alice prima media uomo senza
di segnare così
e stupendo se la mia preferita
anita stories cioè bellissimo grazie
davvero
lo slide verde ovviamente grazie alice
bellissimo sei bravissimo grazie
dantesco potere allora è un cartellone
gigante cos'è il mio personaggio
intrighi la mia foto qua c'è la
copertina del libro c'è è bellissimo
tanti glitter per anni è stata telone
dario da da rosaria da maria francesca e
da vanessa vista luce grazie mille per
la frase che c'è scritto a qualche
carinissima grazie per questo per
gigante altro cartellone è da
lorena grafici da tutti i titoli the
stories la numero 11 si stimoli così
scritto se la migliore da lorena mi fai
sorridere per la queen nudo uno che
carino se importanti così super ti
ammiro ti adoro ad orte e i twins line
ma se la quindi youtube italia che
carine grazie lo re nel bellissimo della
è da miriam grazie e gigante per quello
non si sta in tutta l'inquadratura ma mi
fa troppo ridere questa frase quasi
scritto ho sempre desiderato che servì
da principessa ma i vestiti di anita vi
stanno grandi che carera grazie per
questo meno cartellone
ma è bellissimo grazie al suo disegno da
spaccio disegno da lorena purtroppo si è
trattato come l'abbiamo aperto qua c'è
scritto fallo numero uno dei disegnini
carichissimi portarci sempre il ricordo
castor all'inter stories storie
schiarite vitale grazie mille arriva da
un altro cartellone gigantesco da suoni
o suoni noi di e carol grazie bellissimo
avete visto delle foto de delle nostre
copertine dei video la pit lane gigante
e poi qua al centro città gigante sui
quasi un altro slam gigante e bellissimo
grazie e tre da ludovica irrita e avete
fatto un mega idrato avital ma cliccare
cosa c'è scritto tipo blu vitale e poi
ci sono io qua che carina se disegnato
potere di cosa rinvenibili con quinto
timoroso la coppia preferita anita
vitale cresta fanello grazie mille
l'unica rita state bravissime allora
facce l'ultimo siamo arrivati alla fine
anita vitale se il mondo di allison
chiudo con amore e passione carini
all'eternità li voglio bene le orecchie
di sly grazie chiara cosa c'è anche la
mia maglietta con il simbolo grazie
chiara grazie a tutti per le cose che mi
avete portato ma anche a chi non ha
portato a cose l'importante che siete
venuti bellissimo grazie mille se avete
visto il video fino alla fine la parola
segreta e ti voglio bene
scrivetelo nei commenti se avete visto
il video fino alla fine fino alla fine
isla mente li faccio notare un altro
piloti menti questo video è il
bellissimo sembra registrando da più di
un'ora un'ora e mezzo tipo quindi mi
mando un bacione enorme star esprime li
stiamo il migliore un faccione norme
ammazza poi ciao